- Millions of women across the US
could lose their legal right to abortion.
- This could be the most
consequential opinion in decades.
- From the Supreme Court, it
would overturn Roe versus Wade.
- Raises questions about the
future of Roe versus Wade
and what this means for
abortion rights in our country.
- So this is happening
in the US right now,
and lately, I've been wondering.
Why the (beep) is there not
a birth control pill for men?
It's 2022.
We can make vaccines in like 10 seconds,
we send telescopes into space,
and we can take photos of things
millions of lighters away,
but yet we still have not
figured out how to make it
so that I can take a pill
and not have a baby when I have sex.
We're trying. Look at this
Instagram ad that I got served.
It's like a ultrasound
sperm killer pouch device.
There's actually an appetite
for this. People want it.
I polled all of you.
80% of men are saying
that they would be up
for taking a birth control pill.
So let's talk about birth control.
First, let's start with a
list of the options you have
if you want to have sex
and not have a baby.
There's like 10 options
for women and two for men,
two, condoms and vasectomies,
oh, and I guess pulling
out, question mark?
Oh, and of these two, one
is notoriously unreliable,
and the other one is like permanent.
None of these require us to take something
on a regular basis, put something
in our bodies permanently,
or affect our hormones in any way.
It's not the 1950s anymore.
Why is the burden of birth
control still predominantly
on the partner who
carries the pregnancies?
We got to the bottom of this
through a lot of reporting,
and I wanna show you what the
deal is because in this story,
you will see the dark side of medicine
and why some things get
studied and why others don't.
But you'll also see a bit
of hope in the future.
Like this is slowly changing,
not fast enough though.
Oh, and I'm gonna dive into sex ed
because the details are fuzzy for me.
It's been a while.
(mid-tempo music)
- The human reproductive cycle.
- Let me see!
- What is that?
- [Announcer] The uterus
becomes richly supplied
with blood to.
One sperm succeeds in breaking through.
- Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Welcome to sex ed class.
(triumphant music)
Okay. We're all adults.
I know we know how sex works and things,
but if you're like me, you
don't remember the details.
So I just wanna quickly go
over a couple things that,
to me as an adult, are really
relevant to this discussion.
First, let's talk about hormones.
Hormones are chemicals, but
they're so much more than that.
So let's think of it as an analogy here.
This is your body and all of the veins
and arteries are the internet.
This is how stuff gets around.
Hormones are like emails that are sent
from the managers of the
body, all of these glands.
The managers are telling different parts
of the body what to do,
to change something,
to kick off some certain
process or behavior,
all in the name of
keeping the body balanced
and regulated and healthy.
Everything from digestion
to stress to sleep to mood,
all of this is dictated by hormones,
these emails being sent around
your bloodstream in the form
of chemicals to tell your body what to do.
Okay, so that is hormones.
Now let's talk about how babies are made.
- If it's fertilized by a male sperm cell,
it'll grow into a baby.
- [Announcer] The doctor
lends a helping hand,
and the new baby meets the outside world.
- Every month, a woman's body managers
send out some really important emails.
Remember, emails are hormones.
We're just gonna stick
with the analogy, okay?
The hormones tell this big bag of eggs
to release one of the eggs down this tube
so that it can end up here in the uterus,
the uterus, which has
already received its own set
of emails saying that
the egg is on its way
and please prepare the
place so that it's cozy,
like putting this nutrient-rich lining,
like a nice cozy blanket,
so that the egg has the
best chance of thriving.
So the egg finally arrives
and hopes that a male sperm
will join it so that a
baby can start growing
for the next nine months.
But if the sperm doesn't
arrive on the scene
within like this really narrow
time period, it's like a day,
then the hormone managers send
another set of emails saying,
"Too bad, so sad.
He didn't show up. We're
not reproducing this month.
Let's clear all this lining
out that we created for the egg
and start preparing for next month."
They clear it all out, they
flush out all this blood lining
while the woman is on her period,
and the cycle starts over.
Do you see how this
entire thing plays out?
Because of very specific instructions
that are written and sent by hormones.
They cue each step of this process.
Okay, but most of the time,
you just wanna have sex
and not have this egg and
the sperm meet up, right?
Even though the body really wants that,
you don't necessarily want to have a baby,
and this is why we invented birth control.
- [Announcer] The most
effective of these is the pill.
- Don't forget to take your pill.
- [Bald Man And Mary] I won't.
(audience laughs)
(dramatic music)
- Pause really quick.
I just need to tell you something,
which is one of the questions
I get most often is,
"How do you know so much about
all of these random topics
like male birth control?"
The answer is because
I read a lot of books.
Actually, no, I don't read a lot of books
because I'm super dyslexic
and I don't have time
to sit and read books.
I listen to a lot of audiobooks,
which brings me to
thanking today's sponsor,
which is Audible.
This is really easy for me
because I've been using
Audible for like a decade.
For someone who loves
information but struggles to read
either because it's hard for me to read
or because I just don't
have time to sit and read,
Audible has changed my life.
When you subscribe to Audible,
you get to choose one title a month
of any type of audiobook.
You also get unlimited access
to their Audible originals,
which are only available
to Audible members.
I often just scroll
through here and say like,
"What do I want to listen to for free?"
There's so much good stuff.
Currently listening to an audiobook
from one of my favorite science
explainers, Bill Bryson.
It's called "The Body."
It's a really well written
science explainer book
about the human body and every system.
It like gives you a new
appreciation for your body,
and it allows me to research
and learn about new things
so I can make videos for all of you.
You can try this out for free if you want.
You can have an entire month free.
All you need to do is go to
the link in my description.
It's audible.com/JohnnyHarris
or text Johnny Harris
to 50,-500 and get signed up
for a month of free Audible.
Thank you Audible for
supporting this video.
Let's dive back in. Okay.
Most modern methods of birth control work
by messing around with
the emails being sent
around the body.
Cue the pill.
So a woman takes this
little pill everyday.
Hmm, where's the pill? I have a pill.
This is the pill.
Actually, it's 28 pills
because a woman takes
this every single day,
and it changes everything.
The pill contains a new
batch of emails or hormones
that override the old instructions
and tell the whole system
to do something totally different.
Announcement.
For the next 28 days,
we're under new management.
So the new emails are
coming down to the ovaries
where all the eggs are and
they're like, "Hey guys,
don't do anything this month.
You're fine. Just relax, take a nap."
And the ovaries are like,
"But that means we
won't get anything done.
We're gonna be super unproductive.
We're like the most important thing
for keeping the species alive,"
and the pills are just like,
"Sh take a nap, go to sleep."
Okay, here comes another email.
This time, it's going to the cervix,
telling it to start making
really thick, sticky, mucus.
And the cervix is like, "But wait,
we make mucus that isn't thick,
and we actually try to
make it so it's perfect
so that the sperm can swim
upstream and get to the egg,
and the pills are just like,
"Sh, just do what you're told."
"Oh, and uterus, change the
lining that you're creating
so that it's not very
cozy for an egg to survive
in case one gets through,"
and the uterus does,
and this is how the pill works.
It writes new emails.
It sends new hormones to
tell this whole system
to do something totally different
than what it was programmed by evolution
to do to keep our species
going, and it totally works.
If you want to have sex
and not have a baby,
take this pill everyday,
and there's the downside.
You have to take this pill every day,
and that comes at a cost.
(contemplative music)
(chalk scribbles)
It turns out that changing the hormones
that make it so that this doesn't happen
also has some side
effects because hormones
are not isolated to one system.
They don't just affect this.
You mess with hormones, you
mess with all the systems.
It's an interconnected thing
that changing the level
of one can affect many others.
But listen, who am I to talk about this?
I've never taken this pill.
I've never been on any
sort of hormone treatment.
So let's talk to people who actually have.
- I had never had a panic attack before.
I rarely had anxiety.
When I started taking birth control,
literally everything made me anxious.
- I had very oppressive
and debilitating depression
to the extent I've never felt before.
I would look in the mirror
and wouldn't recognize myself.
My brain felt like mush.
- I didn't realize how
much it's changing me,
how much it affects me
until I stopped taking it.
So I only felt real me
once I stopped taking the birth control.
- Definitely the worst part
was the emotional toll.
I felt like a different
person. I was constantly upset.
I got angry. I was crying.
- Because of the pill,
I developed this giant blood
clot inside of my uterus,
and I had to get it removed.
- Hormonal birth control was
in some ways really awesome,
but at the same time, I
didn't have a sex drive,
and I started birth control
before I started having sex,
so I really thought that there
was something wrong with me.
- It was a very dark time in my life,
and when I went to the doctor,
I asked if the birth control
pill could contribute to that,
and I was basically laughed at.
- It is so frustrating
to deal with side effects
that mess with your mood
and with your feelings
because it's so easy to
just internalize that
and to gaslight yourself and to thinking
that this is just the way you are now.
"I guess I'm just moody.
I guess I'm just grumpy all the time."
And it's hard to take a
step back and to think,
"Am I going through a hard time,
or these side effects from
my birth control pill?"
- It was like a
rollercoaster for two years.
What you don't know is
like when you go off,
your hormones are crazy.
Like you shed hair like crazy.
Like I was pulling out clumps of hairs.
I was like, "Is something wrong with me?"
And then you Google it, and you're like,
"Oh no, that's normal.
That'll last for like
six months to a year."
- This is a very widespread, well known,
well documented thing.
A study from Denmark found
that women who take the pill
that has hormones in it are more likely
to suffer depression
compared to women who don't,
and again, this isn't
just like once a month.
This isn't just like
every once in a while.
This is every single day you
are putting this hormone-modifying
thing into your body.
And is it surprising that some women
have really serious effects with this?
The pill is tampering with arguably
the most biologically
important system we have.
Okay, but really quick, before
you like demonize the pill,
the pill is amazing,
and it's totally safe.
150 million women take it
everyday, and for a lot of women,
it actually helps regulate some
of their hormones that are off balance.
So if you have questions about
birth control and hormones,
don't listen to a random dude on YouTube.
Go talk to a healthcare
professional. Thank you.
I wanna get to male
birth control eventually.
Like that's the reason
you clicked on this video.
That's the purpose. We're going there.
I'm gonna explain mail birth
control, but to get there,
we have to understand
where this pill came from
and the price that women
had to pay to get it,
and then we can all sit
around and ask ourselves,
"Would men be willing to pay that price
to get a pill of their own?"
So let's talk about where
this magic pill came from.
Well before playing around with hormones,
humans were still trying to
have consequence-free sex,
and they basically had one
tool available to them,
which was some form of condom.
Sometimes it was linen.
Sometimes it was animal intestines or,
in Japan, they used tortoise shells.
Wait, what? Tortoise shells?
Oh, tortoise shells. Wow.
That's a great fitting tortoise shell.
What kind of tortoise is this?
Anyway, this is what they used.
Once the material latex was invented,
condoms became very cheap
and widely available,
but you have to understand
that, for a long time,
they weren't trying to not have kids.
They were trying to stop
diseases from spreading.
- [Announcer] But you don't
get them if you use a condom.
- Because children are
a blessing from above.
Why would you want to not have them?
- [Woman] Let me see what you have.
- A knife!
- No!
- But then women in the modern age,
heaven forbid, wanted
to have fewer children,
but they still wanted to
have sex, and unfortunately,
a top way of doing that
was through dangerous
and deadly back-alley abortions.
So in 1916, this nurse from
New York opened a clinic,
and the theme of her
clinic was birth control,
teaching women how not to get pregnant.
By the way, this was like
super illegal at the time
because under this law,
you couldn't publish anything
having to do with sex.
So she's totally breaking the
law teaching women about sex.
Geez, scandalous.
But she fought back
and eventually helped
create Planned Parenthood.
And it was her who led the
charge in creating the pill,
the thing that uses hormones
to stop reproduction
from happening, and in the 60s,
this pill would change everything.
- Equal rights to have
a job, to have respect
and not be viewed as a piece of meat.
- Women have a fundamental right
to control their own bodies,
to control their own lives.
- Women could now have
autonomy over their bodies.
They could go to work and
earn money for themselves
and decide for themselves when
they wanted to have children.
She was a hero, a liberator,
and she was totally racist,
or at least she spoke about
it in a very racist parlance,
referring to it as a tool to help, quote,
"the process of weeding out the unfit
and preventing the birth of defectives."
That's more than racist.
That's called eugenics,
which was a popular pseudoscientific
movement at the time
that was all about
breeding a superior race
and eradicating the unfit,
which these people were able
to deem whoever they wanted.
Poor people, people of color, immigrants,
people with disabilities, all
of them were to be weeded out.
So a inconvenient fact in all of the story
is that a major motivation for the pill
wasn't sexual liberation, but rather,
it was the overpopulation of the earth
with these unfit races and peoples.
But nonetheless, the development
of the pill went forward,
and they decided to do trials on it
to get it ready for market,
and where did they turn but Puerto Rico,
a place where all problems
were blamed on overpopulation,
a perfect testing grounds
for this really twisted,
F'ed up project of
weeding out unfit races.
- [Announcer] Puerto Rico,
a beautiful little island
with a big problem.
- [Woman] In 1956,
contraceptive pills 20 times
as strong as the ones used
today were first tested
among Puerto Rican women who lived
in government housing projects.
- In Puerto Rico, they were
already sterilizing women
to control the population,
and now they were gonna test
out this new experimental pill.
They pitched them like,
"Hey, come do the pill
instead of getting sterilized,"
because they were literally forcing people
to get surgery where they tie the tubes
and they like make it
impossible to have kids.
They started giving them the pill.
Oh, but they forgot to tell them
that they're a part of a trial
for a highly experimental drug
that was gonna mess with their hormones.
(speaks in foreign language)
(soft dramatic music)
- These doctors didn't have
their dosing figured out yet.
So they were giving women pills
that were way more hormonally aggressive
than the ones we have today.
So these women were experiencing
intense side effects,
but the doctors running the
trial told the "New York Times"
that these side effects were,
quote, "largely psychogenic,"
most of them happening
because women expect them.
22 women dropped out of the study
because of the side effects,
and three women died,
but their deaths were never investigated.
But in the end, the trial
was deemed a success.
Eventually, they dialed in the dosage,
and the pill hit the market,
and that's how we got
the birth control pill.
I wish it was a better story.
Like I wish there
wasn't the whole eugenics
Puerto Rico thing.
I wish it was just like some
badass feminist was like,
"We're gonna have less kids,
and we invented this pill
'cause we can, and we're liberated,"
but that's just not how it happened.
It's a reminder that
something so liberating
can also be oppressive,
and that's just a contradiction we're all
gonna have to live with
because life is complicated.
Anyway, today,
the pill is the most popular
birth control method,
at least here in the US.
I was looking at CDC data.
But now we've got other options, too.
Like there's this little T that women
can put in their uterus
for up to 10 years,
and it can either release
hormones to do the same thing,
or it can be wrapped in
copper, which kills sperm,
no hormones at all.
It's 99% effective and the
second most popular form
of birth control, and the
third most popular is a condom,
which, of course, doesn't
release any hormones
and does not get ingested into our bodies.
And it is our one birth control method
that we have as men in
addition to a vasectomy.
(laughs) Like those are our choices.
That's what we've got,
and that is my question.
That is the heart of
why I made this video,
which is like why is all of the tampering
with the hormones to prevent
babies thing a female thing?
Why didn't this history happen to men?
Why don't we have a pill
that sends overwriting emails
to our balls or something?
Well, of course, there's the
obvious unquantifiable reality
that the people holding
the power and the money
and wearing the lab coats
have always been men
who get to decide what to
research and what to focus on,
oh, and that controlling women's bodies
has somehow always been
normalized and still is.
Exhibit A.
- [Female Reporter] The
draft Supreme Court opinion
showing a majority would
overturn Roe versus Wade.
- Overturn the landmark Roe V. Wade case.
- Oh, and of course we live in a society
where women are responsible
for all things babies.
After all, it grows in their uterus.
So it's not that surprising
to me that the scientists
weren't out there
recruiting Puerto Rican men
to participate in some unethical study
about controlling their bodies
and what they can and can't do.
It's laughable to think
about that scenario
because it just would never happen,
but it would be slightly a cop out
if I just left the explanation
at structural sexism,
which is absolutely a thing, it is real,
but there are some other explanations
for why we don't have a
male birth control pill.
Let me break those down for you,
and then let me show you what
options we dudes do have,
which is cool.
Like there's some really
cool emerging stuff.
So let's look into it.
- But I was wondering why
there's so many sperm cells
and only one egg cell.
- Here. Maybe a diagram will help.
- The major legitimate
limitation is biology.
It's a lot easier to stop one egg a month
than it is to stop 180
million sperm blasting out
of you every time you ejaculate.
Blasting. Is that slightly too aggressive?
Anyway, that's a lot to manage,
but scientists are working
on it and making progress.
One of the most promising
studies we found in our reporting
was not a birth control
pill but a hormonal gel.
- This is not a pill.
It's actually a gel that's applied daily
to a man's arm or shoulder.
- And local researchers
think this could be it.
- [Female Reporter] In men
who've used it as directed,
there have been no little surprises.
- The hormones tell your
body to stop producing sperm,
and it works really well in trials.
The trials are being tested in dozens
of places around the world,
and it's definitely the furthest along
of all of the things we looked at,
and they're actually
looking for more couples
to participate in the trial.
So if you wanna participate,
go into the description and check it out.
I would participate,
but in full disclosure
and probably TMI for the internet,
I have two children, and
I'm done having kids,
so I'm gonna get a vasectomy.
That's a story for another day.
There's another method that scientists
are testing called RISUG.
You get a shot in the groin.
I know that sounds terrible,
but you're probably numb and fine,
and the gel from the shot
blocks the sperm from passing.
- You shall not pass!
(dramatic suspenseful music)
(explosion booms)
(sperm scream)
- Research is saying that
the gel can last for 13 years
and that if you want to dissolve it,
you just do a second
injection, and it dissolves.
It was originally developed in India,
but some American companies
have licensed the technology
and are developing similar projects,
but it's still pretty early.
And lastly, there are of course
pills that are being tested.
There are a lot of different
approaches to these pills.
Some of them are hormonal,
like the birth control pill
that was racistly
developed in Puerto Rico,
sending new emails to
sex organs to get them
to not do the thing they're used to doing.
But some of these pills
don't use hormones at all
but rather a Chinese herb
that changes the shape
of the sperm's head to
make it a worse swimmer
so that it can't reach the egg.
It's so funny to me to think of like,
we got too good at like procreating,
and now we wanna stop
it, but evolution's like,
"Dude, we've been trying so
hard to make this easier.
Stop changing the sperms
head to look like a hook!"
There's another pill that cuts
off the special protein found
in the testes that then
stops the sperm production.
It's like all these clever ways
of like reprogramming the body.
It's been 99% effective at
preventing pregnancies in mice,
and the moment they stop taking it,
they bounce right back
to normal fertility.
Very promising on mice.
Clinical trials on humans are supposedly
gonna start this year, like progress?
But do you notice it's like it's 2022.
We've invented all of this amazing stuff,
and we're still in early trials,
like early trials of
all of these inventions.
Like we weren't doing
this in the 70s or the 80s
when they were in Puerto
Rico, messing with people.
We're doing it now.
A lot of these drugs like have a decade
to go before they're even
close to viable to sell,
and that has a lot to do with how we think
about side effects for men.
Hear me out on this.
This is like the most important
part of this entire video,
and if you are still here
watching, just hear me out.
Side effects for men.
There was one study that was canceled
because the safety board deemed
the side effects too severe.
Even though 75% of the participants said
that they would keep going,
that the side effects weren't
too bad, they canceled it.
And what were these side effects?
Feelings of depression, mood swings, acne.
Hmm, sound familiar?
A woman experiencing mood
swings and depression
on a pill is now totally normalized.
Happens every day to millions of women,
and we're okay with it because
it's a small price to pay
to prevent a giant thing like
a child growing inside of you.
But if a healthy man experiences the same
or similar volatile side effects,
we deem it as too severe, unacceptable,
not enough benefit for the
cost of those side effects.
All of this means that experimentation
in male birth control is limited,
which means that no one wants to fund it.
No companies want to invest in it.
It gets chump change in terms of funding.
Like the entire pharmaceutical
industry invested $13 million
into contraceptive research
between 2018 and 2020.
The former CEO of just one
pharma company made more
than double that amount
in just one year alone.
Like we're talking pennies goes into this
because it does not have
long-term viability,
and this is the big failure to me.
It's how we frame our acceptance
of side effects for men
that is at the root of all of this.
If two people are
engaged in consensual sex
and one of them gets pregnant,
then both should be equally affected.
That seems like a no brainer.
That is an obvious thing to say,
but we all tacitly disagree with that
when we deem a woman's risk as higher
and thus we have a higher
tolerance for her side effects.
But that's how it is.
The partner who carries the
pregnancy takes on the role
of birth controller,
even at the expense of the
hormonal balance of their body,
which affects so much more
than just their eggs and their tubes.
And it won't change until
we men step the (beep) up
and start seeing birth control
as something that we both carry together,
the good and the bad,
regardless of our anatomy.
- You students who've
been watching this film,
you've heard the questions
we are going to discuss.
You can discuss these same
questions with your teacher.
- Bah! There goes my uterus.
My precious uterus. Okay.